last week about this time we spoke to
robin frippleton who along with his wife
and two teenage daughters
decided to open their homes to ukrainian
family and they even went to the trouble
of going all the way to poland to pick
them up but red tape in the visa process
means it hasn't happened robin joins me
now from lincolnshire uh great to talk
to you again robin when we spoke last
week you made a direct plea to the home
secretary to change the system now that
afternoon to make it work
what has happened over the last seven
days
uh not a great deal i'm afraid the
morning after we spoke last last week
one of our six families managed to get
to the uk
they they didn't need any biometrics so
is it quite a straightforward process
for them online and i sensed that there
was perhaps a little bit of local mp
influence
for the host family in in that
particular case but
we continue we've backfilled that family
so i still have six families no further
forward in the process and it's been
three weeks and counting
what about i understand one of the
families has dropped out is that is that
true yeah the wait time is is very
unhealthy it's causing
both sides of the equation to question
themselves so we're finding that some of
the families the ukrainian families are
looking online at the downside of the uk
and so on they're also hearing that the
process is
is taking a long time they've got
children and they're getting
increasingly uncomfortable staying on
the floors of polish school houses and
so on
so they're reversing their decisions and
they're getting on coaches that are
going to all the other countries across
europe europe we are an outlier in what
we're doing by holding the people back
in these in these temporary centers of
accommodation
so families that did want to initially
come to the uk are basically just giving
up and and now trying other countries
yeah we're we're seeing that and and so
it's causing people to question and it's
and it's raising their stress levels the
the other thing jane since you and i
last spoke about this that materially
has changed in in the equation is the
home office looking to process or saying
they're going to look to process these
applications within 48 hours and indeed
work through the backlog
if i can give you a very brief window
into how the home office is operating on
the front line
at the moment i spoke last night
to one of our mothers marina she was
called up to go to the center
because her visa was now ready for
collection but she has a seven-year-old
child we took her on a 100 mile round
trip to the center when she got there
she told she was told that it was her
visa that was ready to go but not that
of her seven-year-old boy alexi
uh she put me on loudspeaker i spoke to
the uk representative at the center
and i asked him could you look on the
system please don't turn this lady away
with her child that'll be completely
inhumane and we've been waiting three
weeks i'll call the guy john it's not
his real name i'll save his blushes but
he said no i can't do that rob
um i can't i don't have the telephone
number of the decision center at
sheffield and we're not to call them
and so i
you know that it's incredible that
that's where we're at and of course he
turned her away with her child now
what if she had no accommodation to go
back to last night and what should she
have done with that little boy
it just so happens that she fell back
into our care and we had a room for her
in our little hotel
but it's extraordinary i just wondered
what this chap john thought was then
going to happen to this poor woman that
he was turning away and why he couldn't
make that phone call
so if you were to ask me the same
question now jane
uh if i sat in front of pretty patel or
indeed lord harrington what would i say
i'd say two things i'd say please allow
john to call the decision center in
sheffield because
by not being able to do that it's hardly
the behavior of a high-performing
organization and it's hardly the
behavior of an organization trying to
work through its backlog
and i would also say to them just bear a
thought please for marina's husband on
the other side of the border fighting
this war in very difficult circumstances
he needs to do that without the
distraction of knowing that his wife and
child are being bounced around poland
for three weeks in their visa
process well robin we've spoken to the
government and they've given us a
statement in response they weren't able
to give us an interview they said the
homes for ukraine scheme was set up in
record time but we acknowledge progress
for perusing visas has not been good
enough the home office has made changes
to visa processing the application form
has been streamlined ukrainian passport
holders can now apply online and do
their biometric checks once in the uk
and greater resource has gone into the
system this is allowing us to welcome
people faster while still maintaining
security checks which ensure those who
could pose a threat to our safety are
prevented from getting here and human
trafficking is addressed and rob and i
imagine you would argue to that that
presumably a seven-year-old boy is not
especially a security threat and
unlikely to be trafficked if he's with
his own mum
quite right and that's the point i made
to john last night i said just look in
front of you it's a seven-year-old boy
he's hi he hardly represents a threat to
the to the country i don't know why
you're separating children from their
mothers in this process it's very odd
and and anecdotally there you have it as
of last night you have a warsaw
application center not being able to
speak to
the decision center in sheffield that is
a fundamental breakdown of communication
in that process
well rob and we will keep in touch with
you and do keep us updated as to how
you're getting on best of luck with
those families that you're trying to
bring across thank you thanks a lot